mark please explain this [ __ ] reddit
story that you found oh yeah so i don't
even understand it
telling me what it was
i didn't understand yeah no we talked
about what we're going to talk about
three times you go okay what are we
doing i talked about it once more this
morning with fa i still don't understand
it okay
i truly don't understand you've heard of
reddit yeah okay so that's good somewhat
i know right i've heard of it i know i
understand after that
downhill all right there was a community
called anti-work on reddit okay and
basically there's a community of people
that got together to try to like push
back against like american capitalistic
work structure basically like you got to
work 60 hours a week hustle culture you
got to make all your money blah blah
blah and so garyvee it's like
anti-garyvee more or less yeah and just
like the idea that oh like if you work
hard you'll be successful if you work
hard you'll make money like inflation
wages just haven't gone up blah blah
blah it's like the ethos i guess of the
community and of course because that's
the ethos of the community there are
people that are coming up with solutions
for how to have like a better work
culture in america and some of those
involve like ubi like universal basic
income you have like socialists in there
you've like communists like yo the
government should just pay everyone to
do whatever they want we shouldn't
actually have to work at all blah blah
blah so you have like people that have
dumber ideas in the people why should
the government work
so all that to say you have real quick
just yeah pushing back on the universal
basic income we should just get paid to
do what we want yeah but somebody's got
to work for the government
mm-hmm why do they have to work
well i think the idea is like if
everyone's contributing to the economy
in your own little way that it would
just level out and then you also
government work is not real capitalism
it's mad easy you don't get fired you
get every [ __ ] day off you get raises
every six years i'm just saying if i'm a
government worker and i see a bunch of
people that are just surfing all day
because they get universal basic income
i'm like [ __ ] this why do i have a
[ __ ] job and then somebody needs to
work with the bodega somebody needs to
work at the hospital someone needs to
drive the [ __ ] trains like they're
going to be a couple people that are
screwed and then everybody else still
chills and that's just going to be the
same thing we have now
right yeah i'm not getting people
working jobs that they don't like and
then a bunch of other people now they
might not be incredibly rich but they're
still just not really working while
these people do the jobs that suck
so anyway i don't know enough to defend
it well figure it out okay but there is
a person from the community that's a
moderator that basically runs the whole
community yeah and they have a like
strict policy that none of the
moderators can do like public press
outings they can't do like press
releases they can't do news interviews
they get exposed and yeah and it's like
bad for the community we don't want to
like dfy people within it like this is a
community of like workers trying to like
have solidarity and come together and so
there's one moderator
who
went and like got reached out to by
jesse waters team from fox news yeah and
they were like yo we want to get you on
our show we would love to interview you
and just learn a little bit more about
your platform and what you do and what
you believe in we think would be like
really helpful for our viewers to know
okay
it's a
it's a three minute combo
how many minutes
i assume you have the best minute yeah
right now is the last like minute and a
half like two minutes is is the first
minute her telling us how she puts the
lotion on the skin
[Laughter]
so this is uh this is basically how the
combo goes i didn't get it yeah yeah
it's a uh buffalo bill uh okay got it
got it
a 1990 reference yeah guys
gotta have over here
dude neil young bro
come on man keep on rocking all right so
this is this is more or less the
conversation is this a dude i think it's
a woman it's a trans woman uh
in like the worst webcam in like a
disheveled apartment it's like the worst
spokesperson for like an anti-work
movement of all time virtue in a society
where
people constantly want you to be
productive 24 7 and it's good to have
rest um that doesn't mean you should be
resting all the time or not putting
effort into things that you care about
but i think one of them what do you
think is like a good work day how many
hours is you know a solid work day in
your ideal society
uh
sure i mean i think as much as people
want i mean i personally uh work i have
i have like a 20 25 hour work weeks
which i think is fairly good
um so i would like less work hours
i'm a dog walker a dog
okay
and uh yeah so how old are you if you
don't mind me yeah he's trying
everything not to laugh sure i'm 30.
you're 30. okay why and is there
something you want to do besides being a
dog walker do you aspire to do anything
more than dog walking or is that kind of
your
your pinnacle
uh i love working with dogs if i had to
do this rest of my life you know i
wouldn't just be super complaining you
know dogs are wonderful animals uh but i
mean i would love to teach uh i would
love to
um you know uh work with work with
people and stuff like that what would
you teach doreen
uh a philosophy mostly
critical thinking reason stuff like that
okay
well i would love to take your class
doreen
i would just
be taking notes the whole time and you
know what a professor is a very similar
schedule than
something that you're
imagining so i think that actually might
might work perfectly for you listen uh i
think this might not be the greatest
idea but who am i to judge
to each their own they say it's a free
country
sure not everything and that's basically
the whole convo okay and then this
subreddit of 1.6 million people just
imploded overnight
wow because of this interview basically
like you made a mockery of us like you
made us look so stupid all the bunch of
[ __ ] came out about doreen if you want
to explain that well they just get to
explain like why the subreddits hope set
is because the subreddit felt like they
were actually getting somewhere and they
were like oh like we're slowly like
forming 1.6 million people sort of on
the same page and they were slowly like
moving from
uh
work is bad to like oh people deserve
health insurance if they work so like
they were slowly getting to a place
where they might be able to do something
this interview happens and it goes nuts
on reddit and every other reddit
subreddit shares it it gets picked up by
news sources and anti-work immediately
looks like a big dumb like just what's
so crazy that she said
basically she wants to work 20 25 hours
a week yep
who doesn't
she wants more time to do the thing that
she loves the idea that everyone should
be able to do that
everybody wants that i'm sure
yeah just also that she went on he
should be able to do that and he's
laughing it at her like this is so
childish that you think this is possible
and then she's not really bodying him
the way you would want somebody who's
being he's being really smug about the
whole thing yeah which i was so mean
yeah it felt like i felt a little
condescending yeah but you would think
somebody who's a moderator for this
massive page and this important movement
would have better arguments would body
that [ __ ] like watch your
[ __ ] smug mouth before you think i'm
just some idiot and then she kind of
comes across like just some college kid
yeah yeah yeah you're representing 1.6
million people who have like a good idea
sort of everyone thinks they have a good
idea there and you're gonna go on for
your first our first like news thing as
the community feels and you're gonna
have a shitty webcam you're not gonna
look at the camera and you were chosen
because
she was chosen out of the moderators
because she had done
media work before and then they were
like okay well why weren't you more
media trained she was like oh i've never
done it live like she just had excuses
there was a lot of like sort of
just uh did she have their permission to
like the other moderators permission to
go on this i don't think so that's
another reason i think they're upset she
just did it i'm sure they reached out to
everybody and they found somebody that
they could pretty easily pick apart and
they were like hey let's get you on fox
news and i don't think the other month
this is what fox does i remember when i
would go on these like um fox shows back
in the day they just find like the
tiniest
nonsense stories
that they can dunk on and then just blow
them up yeah i remember being on an
episode of um red eye all the comments
yeah it was great show red eye was a
great show so much fun you could say
whatever the [ __ ] you wanted it was it
was actually the best
like show for comedians to be on they
they just let us [ __ ] rip and it was
great they had liberal comics
conservative comment like everything it
was it was really fun but uh i remember
being on one episode of red eye and
they brought up this story
it was about some college you know
college kids doing something goofy like
yeah we don't wanna
you know we don't wanna no man at school
this day or one of these like silly kind
of things like we wanna rename the whole
school because these names are attached
to a horrible history of blah blah and
then
and i remember just being like uh is
this all that we do here like we just
find these stupid stories and then dunk
on them and like make them bigger than
they are like this isn't even a real
issue i remember the host just looking
at me like
do you not know
like it had dawned upon me like i
thought they were just picking stories
we were just riffing it was just kind of
fun but he literally gave me this look
like that's how media works yeah how did
you know i mean this was intense like
they wanted this person yes yes because
apparently what came out is that she
when before she transitioned has like a
rape allegation
apparently like i don't know if it was
even like closed or if it's like still
pending miles or if like what even
happened to it but yeah basically just
like not a great a good person that
somehow is the moderator of this massive
community that like fox wants to dunk on
to be like yo yeah she wants to be a
teacher yeah you're going to go to
college and like become a professor
you're going to go to school for 10
years while you're walking dogs at 30.
yeah
did she rape before she transitioned i
think so yeah okay i mean that's a good
way to get out of it yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's my job
john is dead
you call me doreen yeah dude
transitioning out of a rape i mean
caitlyn transitioned out of a murder
yeah that's pretty good oh yeah that was
pretty good 100 percent work she's
running for [ __ ] governor yeah
vehicular used to be a manslaughter
that's good [ __ ]
that's good
yeah i don't know man but again it's
like hard for me to it's hard for me to
take it serious because i know like what
they do yeah but here's what sucks is
then it actually worked against this
should just get a few million views and
everybody moves on you're a little
embarrassed as a reddit group whatever
but it's destroyed the entire group yeah
that's that's how weak the group was
yeah yeah what a surprise an anti-work
group is hard to work with
a [ __ ] surprise so i think they made
a new group it was like work reform or
something
that's what it looks like why did it
destroy the group why not just kick this
girl out it's like oh you didn't
represent us properly and then she had a
meltdown
the top moderator then made a post and
then had a meltdown and people were like
yo why did you do this why weren't you
more prepared like how were you chosen
to do this yada yada and
she basically didn't defend herself well
if you could imagine in the comments and
then eventually start deleting stuff and
like creating burner accounts
and then just shut the whole thing she's
the top moderator she's the cool handle
yeah yeah she's top dog it's actually
back up
yeah it's back up and they have now 1.7
what they call them idlers
okay why do they call millers they're
idle like their slogan is unemployment
for all not just the rich
unemployment for all not just the rich
yeah
it also she as the moderator goes
against sort of like the new thought
process of that subreddit so she was
began when it was really small and they
were like they were super like no one
should have to work you should be able
to do whatever you want and then slowly
it just became a subreddit where people
were like oh yeah don't work for
[ __ ] don't work for bad people yeah
no i see validity there when you see
somebody working a a job that sucks like
60 70 hours a week they're not paid well
they're [ __ ] miserable like work hard
is cool but that person to what end
you're going to work hard and get
promotions as a job you [ __ ] hate
yeah like i see that we get to work hard
because we love what we do and so we
inspire each other we push each other
you work hard you're doing something you
want to do you're lucky but for a lot of
people it's not that for a lot of people
it's i hate my job yeah you don't want
to encourage laziness but i understand
how you're not inspired to work hard
exactly but the idea of just like not
working at all it's insane what that
well
it's not only insane but what it really
is is just outsource your work to poor
people of color
or automation that's what yeah but like
you can't automate everything i think
that's the goal not yet okay
it's the goal but it's not going to be
here for the next what 50 years minimum
maybe 100 years who knows and there's
certain things you're just not going to
be able to automate right do you know
why big corporations want to automate so
they don't have to pay you at all yeah
they can fire you 100 but they're saying
that they should have some sort of
universal basic income uh in order to
like supplement them for that and maybe
we do work towards that and that's that
can happen that's fine but in the
current state it's just going to be like
throw all that work over to those brown
people over there
work to those [ __ ] asian people over
there throw the work to those black
people over there so it's funny that
this progressive movement is really just
going back to
cheap labor for minorities and taking
advantage of them this is the take
advantage of poor people movement but
just not the poor people in your country
this is apple [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
but they must know that and there has to
be some smart people here who've like
really studied you know marxism and
figured out how to make every
intellectual argument as to why
capitalism is horrible i mean isn't the
whole idea with capitalism being
horrible is that it's taking advantage
of certain groups yeah exploitation
exploitation of groups so why are they
okay exploiting the groups that are
outside the country or are they not and
i'm mischaracterizing their argument
but i mean i'm sure they would say it's
a mischaracterization right like if all
people are doing what they want and then
you just automate the bottom floor then
you'll still have a functioning economy
et cetera et cetera also money can just
be printed from the government it
doesn't even mean anything so just give
everyone money right
yeah i don't think that which isn't
exactly i mean it's kind of true but
also most subreddits are an echo chamber
and so usually when there's nobody's
pushing back yeah
the outside opinion that does got come
in the group then everybody attacks that
person yeah
exactly yeah i mean we're not saying
capitalism is perfect i don't think
that's the the argument but it's like is
it the best one that we've thought up so
far
probably
i don't know a better one and if a
better one did exist we'd probably all
be using it
yeah i don't i mean listen
we act like communism is great in theory
is it though
i want to flex on a [ __ ] every
now and again
communism is great if you suck and
you're broke
yeah right it's not great if you're
great that's what you're doing great
wants to live in a communist society i'm
saying it doesn't account for human
aspirations and emotions
like some people i want to be the best
of the best that's a human emotion you
can't account for in common so if you
like communism you got no faith in
yourself